Bối kì đại của đảng là một giống mốt quan trọt để đam ta xác định tư dùi tâm nhìn,
nhưng quên sách chiến lượng để đến nước ta tích tục phát triển.
Đây hồi đại biểu toàn gục lần thứ mối bối của đảng,
sự kiến tổ chức từ ngày mời chỉ đăng bột năm nay nghiệm công trọng hai rời sấu,
tới ngày 2,5 năm thống bột năm nay nghiệm công trọng hai rời sấu tại tụi hòa nội,
bớm một nghiệm năm trọng tảm esấu đại biểu,
đại dịn cho hơn năm triệu đảng viên, dự đại hội.
Dính ra trong bối cảnh đến nước ta tật liếp thành cụ to lớn,
coi như lịch sử sau bối 15 mới,
đây là sự kiện chính trị trọng đại của đảng và sân tổ ta,
là một giống mốt lịch sử của đất nước trong thật đại hồ chi Minh.
Lánh giấu xù ở tụi trên thống nha năm phát hiện của sức tọng để vấn mềm chào kiến với mới.
Bối phương châm, đoàn két, dân chủ, kỳ cương, đột phát phát triển.
Đây hồi xét thảo lội thông qua các bạn kỳ quán trọng,
bước định đi với tệ chiến lượng,
sẽ được một tiêu và các giải pháp đột phát,
nhằm đưa đến nước ta với vào khi người phát triển mới,
tết tổ phát triển nhàng, bình vấn.
Đây hồi xe bầu ra bản chất hành trường đảng khoảng 14,
vô bí đồng chỉ thật sự tiêu biểu với bạn lĩnh chính trị của phát.
Chỉ tội, quyết tính, đường năng lượng lấy đạo,
đạo nếu yêu cầu, giều vụ lấy đạo đến nước trong về đột phát triển mới.
Dính ra kỳ về phát của đảng,
thà đại hồ đại biểu toàn cú lần thứ mình bố của đảng.
Vấn nhiên, tiền, ý chỉ và khác bọc.
Dính tổ thà sẽ phát triển đằng trụ lực từ cường từ tiêm
thì in mại trong tiêm mệt phát triển mới,
bình hoa bình đặc lập dân trụ,
giáo mại, phố bình, phân mình, hại phục,
bước bước đi lên trụ nếu sao hồi.